qu'est ce que tu fous là tony rien moi
je suis là quoi on papa héros pas prête
pour une brésilienne quoi quoi
visiblement les brosses à dents aussi se
lève parfois du mauvais poil est bon ça
va charles mais le top des oignons moi
je sors peut-être pas souvent mais c'est
pour les grandes occasions ravasi moi
aussi en gros chat j'ai fait la première
saison presque partout ça n'a ni queue
ni tête
qu'est ce que tu viens fouet par chez
nous voleurs de poule h le pavot leur
jeu travailleurs indépendants le globe
sachant que la fréquence de la police
rapport avec la 4g ça allait on se
dépêche pas tous enclins que signifie
cette agitation
ça a l'air sympa ici